she's had more than a decade in the game
and is the highest ranked female referee
in english football
today rebecca welsh makes history
becoming the first woman referee to be
appointed to a game in the efl
not something i thought that when i
decided to be a referee 11 years ago
that
i would i wouldn't i would be in the
football league you know doing the game
being the first female like that
just just didn't even register on the
radar hopefully this season if
if i'm in a position to be promoted then
i will but it's all done on merit
and if it's not me i've got no doubt in
the next 10 15 years we will see a
female left in the premier league
it's not just a personal success but for
the wider sport
officials are thinking about how to get
the next wave of women into the game
and also consider alternative paths in
football
it's a start and we're in a better place
today than we was
two weeks ago so every step has got to
be a positive step
and absolutely we just hope the ball
runs fair for her and she has a great
game she's going to be with a good team
which is going to have
maximum support and it only can
lift the recruitment of young ladies
into the game
rebecca welsh's appointment is a key
moment
officials have called her a trailblazer
and
for women's clubs like wandsworth
borough fc
they say she's leading the way for
change
nobody ever really said you can be a ref
and i think
like with that opportunity now being
brought up to the forefront and bringing
it to the men's game it's going to
obviously bring a lot more ideas
into young girls and older women as well
when i was growing up there wasn't
many role models in football for women
and it was a lot of men
um and especially hearing the likes of
rebecca welsh now being a referee in the
efl
it's just an amazing accomplishment i
also heard that she started her career
quite late
at 27 so that's even even better for our
senior players as well that there's
still hope
that we can do other things in the game
as harrogate town take on port vale this
afternoon
it will not just be one of the biggest
games of rebecca's career to date
but a leap forward for the sport
hinisha sethi sky news